John Federman
the senator from Pennsylvania who is now
dressing like a plumber onto the on the
floor of the United States Senate and
actually had Chuck Schumer change the
rules for him John Federman
broke down crying on the floor of the
Senate because I live in a political
environment I was ridiculed and made fun
of because I wasn't able to process this
thing sometimes or say things think so
I'm so sorry that I'm sure many of you
had to go through this kind of thing you
know I was lucky that I was
I was lucky enough to go through my life
the vast majority of that without this
kind of disability that I have but um
but again I can't imagine and how the
the challenges and I and I admire you
know everyone that has to kind of live
with these kind of struggles and and
Prevail over them
I have a great deal of sympathy for John
Federman I'm not going to
join the chorus of people just making
fun of him for crying
I'm sure he's in a great deal of pain I
have no doubt that he sincerely was
depressed when he was checked in for
depression at that medical center and
I bet he's going through a lot
it's very difficult
he
he is not fit to be a U.S senator and
he's in this role and that is not
conducive to flourishing personally for
him or nationally for us
I'm I'm not making fun of him I'm not
calling him all sorts of names it pains
me greatly when people feel bullied and
uh insulted and low about themselves it
pains me I hate that I hate seeing that
I I
I really feel for the guy I sincerely
feel for the guy the solution to that is
for him to resign he is not fit for the
job
if if he can't figure out how to put on
a a jacket
If he if he can't conduct the basic
business of the Senate
this is not the place for him
and he got himself elected Senator and
that's great and that's an
accomplishment but
the circumstances of his life were such
that he is not fit for this job if the
job of Senator still matters at all I
guess this this is what ties in with the
first part that we were talking about
today which is does the senate ratify
treaties does the senate conduct War
does the senate or declare war rather
does the senate really do the business
of government or is the Senate just kind
of a facade is it a little bit of a club
that works around the margins and
approves judges and has some modicum of
power but is the business of government
really conducted more in these agencies
by unaccountable faceless bureaucrats
who don't really need to worry about
government shutdowns who don't really
need to worry about elections who does
is the Senate just kind of a joke
the longer that John fetterman remains
in the U.S Senate even with the
pressure to do what little power the
Senate has
or to wield what little power the Senate
has is going to be very hard on him and
he's probably going to cry more and he's
probably going to break down more and
that's a sad thing
but also the longer he remains in the
senate in this condition the clearer and
clearer it is
that the Senate is not what we once
thought it was
it's the government happens elsewhere I
think zelinski is just trolling us at
this point I think that Vladimir
zielinski at this point is just trying
to get Americans to root for Vladimir
Putin something that would have been
Unthinkable a few years ago but he's I
think he's trying
zelinski
hot on the heels of hiring a radical
American spokesman who as the military
spokesman for Ukraine was threatening to
kill American journalists
hot on the heels of that zielinski has
hired
an actual witch to be his ambassador
you might say Michael witches aren't
real first of all which is our real but
second of all even if witches weren't
real this is a woman
who does very explicit occult activities
of witches even even if you don't think
witches are real this woman does think
witches are real and zelinski just hired
her to be an ambassador to be a face of
the country it's not even like hiring
her to be the cook though she's very
good at Spirit cooking it's not even
like hiring her to go do some back
Office Accounting or something when you
are an ambassador you your entire job is
to be the face of your country to
represent your country around the world
or around various sectors and he's hired
a witch her name is Marina Abramovich
you've probably heard that name because
of the Wikileaks emails from the podesta
brothers remember Tony podesta very
powerful lobbyist and art collector and
all-around creep if you look into the
kind of art he collects and Affairs that
he's involved in and John podesta was
running Hillary Clinton's campaign in
2016 and there was a Wikileaks email
inviting John
from by Tony to a spirit cooking dinner
led by
Abramovich and spirit cooking is just an
occult Satanic ritual
at the time the official fact Checkers
debunkers on the left they came out and
said
this is not a Satanic ritual we know
what it looks like it looks occult and
witchy and weird but it's not Marina
Abramovich is an artist and this is
merely a performance art piece that
happens to resemble and depict an occult
or Satanic ritual but Marina Abramovich
actually contradicted that herself I
have it pulled up right here the quote
from Marina brahmovich she she said in a
2013 Reddit q a
whether her occult Contemporary Art is
merely art or if it's an actual occult
ritual and what she said was everything
depends on which context you are doing
what you are doing if you are doing the
occult magic in the context of art or in
a gallery then it is Art if you are
doing it in different context in
spiritual circles or private house or on
TV shows it is not art the intention the
context for what is made and where it is
made defines what art is or not that's
only half true I don't I don't actually
think that you can worship Satan
ironically and I do think that when we
engage in art that is occult and satanic
that actually does endanger our souls
but put that
spiritual Point aside for a second
let's just take her at her words the
spirit cooking that involved the
podestas the people running the Hillary
Clinton campaign was to take place in a
private apartment
so even by abramovich's own standards
they were engaging in witchcraft they
were engaging in an occult Satanic
ritual that was not merely art
which tells you everything that you
already knew about Hillary Clinton and
her Circle of Friends
but it also tells you a lot about
zielinski what the hell is this guy
thinking why is he trying to get us to
root for Vladimir Putin I don't want to
root for Putin but this guy's making it
really hard not to
and I can I can think of only two
explanations here
either
zelinski is involved in this stuff
either zelinski looks with a kind eye on
occult Satanic rituals or and this might
be even more distressing
zielinski knows that the American
conservatives don't want to give him
another Penny the only people who want
to keep funding his war or his I mean
say a charitably his defense of the
Russians which seems like a doomed
Endeavor anyway so the question as far
as I'm concerned is just how much longer
is this thing going to drag on
but regardless
zielinski knows that his bread is only
going to be buttered by the Democrats
and he thinks that the way to appeal to
Democrats is to hire witches to be his
ambassadors and I I guess that's worse I
guess the cynical read is even worse he
thinks well you know the only way to get
the American Democrats to support us is
to worship Satan and to get
which is to be the face of our country
that's that's a very sad thing
says even more about us than it says
about zielinski what a great clip that
was now make sure
make sure
that you ring that Bell And subscribe to
the Michael Knowles Channel now